sí de acuerdo de hecho se habían elegido
unos temas principales para hacer este
para hacer las preguntas para este
debate y fueron cambiados pues este
gracias a que la agenda pues ha cambiado
en estas últimas semanas será un debate
moderado por el periodista y presentador
chris wallace del fox news sunday un
periodista de renombre con un buen
historial y que no titubea la hora de
hacer preguntas fuertes y que pues ha
sido bastante fuerte anteriormente con
el presidente trump el debate tendrá una
extensión de 90 minutos de los cuales
habrá 66 segmentos y sólo se dará 15
minutos a cada participante para
responder sus preguntas y los temas en
específico serán la pandemia del coi 19
la nominación del nuevo miembro de la
corte suprema los informes que pesan
sobre el trump y baida en la economía el
racismo y la integridad del proceso
electoral
vanessa como consideras que llega a cada
candidato a este debate en términos de
imagen de aceptación pública
bueno será un debate bastante reñido e
interesante que sin duda sin duda dará
de qué hablar sabiendo que ambos
candidatos tienen personalidades bien
definidas y posiciones fuertemente
marcadas y totalmente contrarias y que
se verán claramente a la hora de debatir
los temas propuestos para hoy tenemos a
un candidato que probablemente no sea el
más diplomático a la hora de dirigirse a
aquellos que se oponen a sus propuestas
cuestión que vimos por ejemplo en
elecciones pasadas cuando se enfrentó a
hillary clinton y tenemos otro candidato
que no parece estar en su mejor momento
y que en ocasiones hasta ha olvidado su
discurso obviamente pues hay más de un
debate son tres debates no veremos
quizás un resultado hoy creo que la
balanza se puede inclinar a cualquier
lado las encuestas no son un indicativo
principal de lo que puede ser el
resultado sabiendo que anteriormente por
ejemplo este hemos tenido a trump
por ejemplo a hillary clinton en
relaciones pasadas liderando las
encuestas en contra en elecciones en
contra trump y ha sido trampa que ha
ganado en estados claves como florido
carolina del norte y al final pues hay
resultados que el resultado por ejemplo
el colegio electoral es el que realmente
determina quién será el ganador
vanessa por las muchísimas gracias por
estos minutos en france 24